ja der Blick man guckt raus und man
fühlt sich frei man ist hier schneller
in der 27 Etage wie woanders in der
dritten Etage ich hatte ein kleines
bisschen Höhen Angst die habe ich jetzt
nicht mehr als es gebrannt hat war das
natürlich spektakulär springen ist keine
Option von hier oben ja
134 m hoch 45 Etagen je höher desto
exklusiver in 968 Wohnungen fast 2000
Menschen das unicenter eine der größten
Wohnhäuser Europas drei Wohntürme der
Superlative die Geschichten erzählen von
Glück und Unglück Spaß und Angst
Anonymität und
miteinander man lernt sich kennen über
die Jahre und auch schätzen und das ist
eigentlich eine schöne Gemeinschaft hier
man kann aber auch total anonym wohnen
Oliver Schinz ist seit 34 Jahren
Pförtner im unicenter an ihm muss jeder
vorbei der rein will denn klingeln gibt
es nicht und auch ansonsten ist er
Mädchen für alles vielleicht es gibt
nichts was man sich da nicht vorstellen
kann jeder hat irgendwas wo wo der Schuh
drückt und hat keinen den er Fragen kann
und wen kann er fragen wer ist immer da
und ansprechbar das halt die Rezeption
los geht's vor genau 50 Jahren mit der
Eröffnung des betonkolosses mitten in
Köln Baukosten 90 Millionen DMark nun
sei der Bauherrschaft gedacht ihr sei
der dank gespendet dass sie mit Großmut
und bedacht die Not des Wohnens hat
gewendet
viel Wohnraum auf kleinster Fläche das
ist sogar einen schnapswert es ist im
Grunde genommen ja wie ein vertikales
Dorf sage ich mal wohen ja wirklich sehr
sehr viele
Menschen jeglicher Herkunft aus jeder
Schicht das finde ich ist so das
Besondere wir treffen neun Menschen auf
sieben Etagen Einblicke ins Hochhaus
Leben Schar Neuerburg und ihr Freund Bl
seit einem Jahr im unicenter in der 30
Etage herzlich willkommen das ist unsere
kleine aber feine Wohnung im unicenter
m knapp 67 madr haben wir glaube ich mit
gefühlt fast noch mal genauso großen
Balkon mit echt tollem Ausblick ja hier
fühlen wir uns eigentlich echt sehr wohl
hier haben Sie es sich gemütlich gemacht
mit 80 Pflanzen ihren eigenen kleinen
Urwald geschaffen auch wenn der erste
Eindruck damals alles andere als
gemütlich ist sind es die inneren Werte
die sie über Zeugen drin sind meistens
sehr schöne Wohnungen und man schaut ja
selber nicht drauf das stimmt und man
ist hier so ein bisschen höher man hat
wirklich eine sehr tolle Sicht und ich
meine die Lage ist auch perfekt ich habe
ber nur auf dem Dorf gelebt und hab dann
einen krassen kontrastwechsel gehabt in
den 30 Stock von daher war es für mich
was völlig neues Leben im Hochhaus die
tyücken lernen Sie schon beim Einzug
kennen das einzige was noch übrig war
war dieses S und wir haben den Aufzug
leider nicht ganz so genau vermessen und
dann haben unsere wirklich sehr sehr
guten
Freunde gesagt nee das packen wir es
gibt ein großes Treppenhaus 30
Stockwerke nach
oben ja wir haben eigentlich gerechnet
dass wir zwei Stunden beschäftigt sind
war in der Viertelstunde 20 Minuten oben
sechs Mann abwechselnd getragen aber
alle waren schweißnass als
irgwann es ist der Ausblick der für
vieles entschädigt das sagen sie alle
vor allem der Blick auf den Dom der nur
23 m höher ist als das unicenter selbst
in der 34 Etage lebt Franz Jürgen
schrohwangen er ist Bewohner der ersten
Stunde und freut sich seit 50 Jahren
über den Blick auf das Wahrzeichen ja
natürlich das ist sehr wichtig in
Köln und ist auch immer wieder wenn ich
Besucher habe oder so das ist so das
Highlight ich habe mal gelesen dass der
Dom lick alleine 1000 Mark im pro
Quadratmeter wert wäre als er das
unicenter 72 damals noch im Bau sieht
ist er sofort überzeugt vom Hochhaus
flir ja ich habe
erstmal gestaunt und mir fiel die Idee
sehr gut
und ich dachte und die günstige
Verkehrslage und das Grün drumrum und
man ist nicht weit aus der Stadt raus
das war wichtig für mich ich bin kein
Typ für Häuschen mit Garten ne war ich
auch nie son wä ich ja nicht hier
hingezogen
1973 kauft er mit seiner Frau die
mittlerweile verstorben ist eine Wohnung
zunächst im 13 Stock 40 quadr für 80.000
Mark hier bekommen sie ihre Tochter die
wie viele andere Kinder im Hochhaus groß
wird spielen in der Betonwüste kein
Problem ist ja auch eigentlich nicht der
Sinn dass man ein Haus nach den Kindern
baut was eben wirklich für Kinder da
sein müsste wäre eine Möglichkeit wo sie
hingehen könnten und immer die gleichen
Leute treffen also so schön diese
sandkastenfreundschaften mit unserer
Tochter hatten wir Glück da war hier
unten noch ein Kindergarten eine
Kindertagesstätte die gibt's heute nicht
mehr in dem Sinne aber
etwas drüben hat die Stadt dann eine
neue gebaut die ist für die Kinder viel
schöner als hier in so einem Hochhaus
auf dem Parkplatz spielen zu müssen
später kauft schrohwangen die größere
Wohnung im 34 der Kaufpreis günstig für
Köln die Nebenkosten aber liegen bei
monatlich 10 € Pro quadratmeer dafür
habe ich die Annehmlichkeiten nicht ich
muss keine Straße feggen auch
Treppenhaus putzen oder so das ist alles
hier in den Preisen drin ne und da ist
das natürlich logisch dass das teurer
ist und Aufzüge muss nicht die Treppen
steigen und so immerhin ist es eines der
modernsten Hochhäuser seiner Zeit vor
allem die Rezeption vermittelt
schrohwangen schon damals ein Gefühl von
Luxus für jeden Eigentümer eine Nummer
der einzige der die Gesichter kennt die
sich dahinter verbergen ist der Portier
doch manchmal ist auch eher
ratlos
hallo als alleinstehendes Ehepaar im
Hochhaus was haben Sie von dieser
Wohnung erwartet und wie weit sind diese
Erwartung erfüllt
worden Kurzformel gebracht individuelles
Wohnen isoliertes wohnen Kontakte nach
Bedarf Komfort bezüglich Versorgung
einkaufseitig für die Hausfrau die muss
das Haus gar nicht mehr verlassen denn
das Einkaufserlebnis bietet sich direkt
vor Ort sogar Schwimmbad Sauna und ein
Kino gibt's die Überreste heute ein
wenig trostlos ein Gefühl das auch ihn
damals schon
quält mit 2000 Einwohnern eine etwas
ungewöhnliche Aufgabe für einen
Briefträger welche Erfahrung haben sie
gemacht keine guten wieso man kennt die
Leute nicht und man lernt sie nie
kennen früher ein Problem mittlerweile
Routine Oliver Schinz hat heute
jedenfalls schon über 150 Pakete
angenommen und auch sonst geht das
unicenter mit der Zeit
Aufzüge die mit zinhalb Stunden
Kilometern unermüdlich hin und her
Rasen Fernwärme durch fette Heizungs
Rohre getrieben und 12500 l
warmwseraufbereitung ein Relikt aber tut
immer noch seine Arbeit der alte
schiffsdieselmotor im Keller des Hauses
das ist unser Notstromagregat der ist
für den Allgemeinstrom im Haus im Fall
eines
Stromausfalls ist ein 50 Jahre alter
Magirus
Deut 16 Zylinder mit genügend Leistung
um alles im Haus zu versorgen was halt
versorgt werden muss der sich früher wie
heute verdient macht sogar im
Dauerbetrieb Mitte der 80er Jahre gab es
hier ein grö größeren technischen Defekt
im Haus wo der fast eine Woche lang ein
Haus mit Strom versorgen musste weil
eine Trafostation abgebrannt war
hässlich und charmant zugleich kommt das
unicenter daher Geschäfte und
Dienstleister im Erdgeschoss sogar eine
chillige Eventlocation im 29 die
sturmfreie Bude mietbar für Feiern und
Kongresse in luftiger
Höhe doch im der Jahre gerät das
unicenter immer wieder in die
Schlagzeilen neben PCE Skandalen
Selbstmördern und geretteten
fensterputzern kommt es immer wieder mal
zu Brenden in und am
unicenter in der 27 Etage haben genau
das Anfang des Jahres auch Julian Smith
und sein Freund Lars Kraus
erlebt wir saß auf der Couch und ich
habe ja zum lar gesagt riecht do hier
nach Brand oder so und dann sagt er nein
Quatsch das kann doch gar nicht sein das
kann doch gar nicht sein ich sagte ich
riech Brand und das weiß ich n wir haben
Flur gegangen der ganze Flur war schon
zugenebelt und dann wollten wir halt
runtergehen und auch die Treppe die
Nottreppe war auch alles schon
zugenebelt aber gab so ein kleines
Moment wo man dachte uh aber man hat
sich natürlich auch so ein bisschen
gesettet hat dann festgestellt der Brand
ist in der vierten Etage man ist jetzt
irgendwie 23 Etagen weiter oben die
Feuerwehr hat das alles im Griff ne es
bringt jetzt nichts die Wohnung
fluchtartig zu verlassen springen ist
keine Option von hier oben ja die beiden
sehen es gelassen denn das Miteinander
im Haus entschädigt für
vieles so ein Hochhaus denkt man ja
eigentlich es es sehr anonym sehr sozial
schwache Menschen wohnen hier das E nur
Vorurteile in dem Fall man kann anonym
bleiben wenn man möchte aber meistens so
wie kontaktfreudig bei sind wir treffen
immer Freunde hier und dann Silvester
gucken wir uns dann über auf den auf der
Kölner Seite natürlich an wie die
Raketen da hochgen und dann stoßen wir
an mit ganz vielen Freunden das ist
immer ein Highlight also das sage ich
auch im Hochhaus Silvester ein muss noch
weiter oben in der 39 Etage wohnt Jod
Skinner mit seinem Freund seit 23 Jahren
schon beim ersten Betreten des
unicenters ist er ihm verfallen ich war
zu Besuch und ich habe sofort gesagt ich
gebe alles auf E ich wollte immer immer
in einem Hochhaus möglichst hoch wohnen
wir haben Sonne vormittags und
nachmittags und wir haben unsere Ruhe
bzw wenn man den
die die Lautstärke aufdreht könnte man
rauschen hören ist Verkehrslärm für uns
mehres Rauschen 140 mm maisesonette
Luxus mit Ausblick in zwei Richtungen so
schön dass Jod Skinner sogar in der
Pandemie nichts vermisst hat wir waren
teilweise 15 Tage nicht vor die
Wohnungstür gegangen und wir haben uns
nie eingesperrt gefühlt das ist
natürlich etwas gefährlich weil man
guckt nur man fühlt sich frei aber und
man geht nicht raus was er aber
mindestens genauso schätzt am Leben im
unicenter das Gefühl dass man nicht
alleine ist aber dass man allein sein
kann also in den Aufzügen man grüßt und
man verabschiedet sich mit tschüss wir
kennen natürlich sehr viele Leute nach
20 Jahren hier im Haus und trotzdem hat
man sein eigenes Leben es ist ein Kosmos
für sich mit Menschen jeglicher Herkunft
vor allem von der ersten bis zu 25
den hier wohnen rund 340 Studierende
sowie Jurastudentin SED gülmes
vollmöblierte 20 quadratm für nur
275 € unina ein
Volltreffer wie ich internationale
Menschen deutsche Menschen ich kann
meine deutsche verbessern ich kann mit
anderen Menschen von
Anges auch oliv wird es nie
langweiligier etwas wie damals als ein
Bewohner seine neue Halle nicht aus den
Augen lassen will da hat mit in die
Wohnung genommen und er ist auf dem Flur
damit Probe gefahren SAS haben wir auch
schon gehabt das haben wir aber auch
später erst mitbekommen weil die
Nachbarn darüber beschwert haben sag das
gibt's doch gar nicht dass ja am
flurradot Motorrad fährt und was ist bei
Sturm im Hochhaus wenn man sich nach
gewöhnt ist dann kriegt man auch ein
bisschen Angst man merkt schon das
Gebäude schwingt leicht m und merkt man
an die Pendellampen unser Kind noch
klein war in der Badewanne und das
Wasser noch drin hatte und es stürmte
dann schwappte das Wasser man sieht der
Sturm von frechen Kommens mit Donner und
Blitz ist ganz herrlich und schrohwangen
setzt noch einen drauf denn 92 erlebt er
sogar ein Erdbeben das war immerhin mit
Stärke 59 hier und ich kannte das
Geräusch nur wenn der Beton knirscht aus
Tokio da hat ich jeden Monat eins ne
also insofern war das an sich auch schon
ein guter Test dass das alles stabil
gebaut ist arm und reich und Jung und
Alt alle unter einem Dach ein Haus das
viele Geschichten erzählt Schandfleck
für die einen Wohntraum für die anderen
aber eins ist
unbestritten das beste hier ist
natürlich die Aussicht das sahehäubchen
auf jeden Fall das ist eine Art Sucht
und wenn man das nicht mehr hat den man
wie leben die Menschen wie leben die
Menschen ohne Ausblick
entweder man liebt es oder man hasst es
das höchste Dorf am
Rhein